In parks and streets across London,...
...people turned out in the hundreds of thousands to celebrate the royal wedding.
Here in Clapham Common, just a few miles from Westminster Abbey,...
...the service played on a big screen to 2,000 flag - waving fans.
For a country normally reserved about overt shows of patriotism,...
...Britain became a sea of Union Jack flags.
As Prince William and Catherine Middleton read their vows,...
...cheers rippled across the crowd.
From fish and chips served from a traditional London bus,...
...to strawberries and cream, every facet of British culture seemed to be on show.
Thousands of street parties have taken place across Britain.
Battersea in London is one of the most diverse communities in the capital.
Here, neighbors and businesses came together to celebrate...
...and in some cases, make a bit of money.